[Music]
for fans of matt groening's sci-fi
comedy futurama it may seem like a
millennium has come and gone since we
last saw the planet express crew in
action it's hard to believe that a full
22 years have passed since the show made
its auspicious premiere on fox and that
it's been eight years since its
bittersweet finale brought it to a close
the series fractured runs so it earn a
handful of emmys score a fiercely
devoted fan base and make a legitimate
case for being one of the best animated
series of all time regardless the show
constantly struggled with ratings and
was cancelled by fox after four glorious
seasons only to be reborn on comedy
central with the restructured
direct-to-video films then unfortunately
it was cancelled again after an
additional two seasons low ratings and
cancellations aside every step of the
way graining and company consistently
made futurama that rarest of animated
series one that could easily make you
laugh out loud or openly weep into the
cosmos the show's blend of low brow
humor high-minded insight and raw
unabashed emotion is what helped make
futurama a cult hit in its initial run
on fox it's also a big reason the series
storied legacy only grew in syndication
which ultimately led to its revival on
comedy central and it's why even after
that unexpected gift of a 60-plus
episode revival futurama fans still
clamor for even more cosmic adventures
with the planet express gang we can't
say for sure whether or not another
season of futurama might eventually be
on the horizon though with each passing
day the prospect of new episodes full of
humor heart and random pop culture
references seems about as likely as
ridding yourself of a brain slug of your
own free will
hopes
deleted the only ray of optimism we can
offer is that the cast sounds excited to
get back in the spaceship voice actor
maurice lamarche told sci-fi wire that
the old cast remains in touch and that
they're all ready and willing to head
back to the recording booth should more
episodes arise he went on to say i have
to leave it up to the powers that be but
i know everybody's into it including the
cast so hopefully someday there will be
a futurama reboot but we're well
practiced at the reboot thing since the
cast is willing and now that disney
acquired 20th century studios perhaps
they will want to revive the show seeing
how it still has a fervent fan base
stranger things have happened especially
in the world of futurama guess this is
your lucky day pimperoo
however some longtime viewers have
wondered whether we actually need new
episodes of futurama those fans point
out that all good things do eventually
come to an end and many of the best
things come to an end a little quicker
than most that's especially true of
television thanks to poor ratings some
brilliant shows with amazing potential
became history way too soon and then
there are others that stay on the air
many years past their prime
i know what you mean
either way most fans agree that futurama
ended exactly the way it should have
back in 2013. that's due to the fact
that comedy central's brass did
something fox didn't do so many years
ago they gave the show's creators a
heads up that the end was near that
inside info allowed the futurama team to
ensure that the series received a
fitting swan song one that tugged on the
heartstrings as much as it tickled the
funny bone
quit touching my junk pervert
the show's finale simply titled
meanwhile more than achieved that goal
graining and company imbued the episode
with all the wit wonder and insight
you'd expect from the series icing the
cake with a ravishingly romantic
storyline rarely seen in the annals of
animated television as many have pointed
out new futurama episodes might seem
extraneous in the wake of that finale
not just because meanwhile was such an
effective series end but also because
fond farewells are so rare in an era
where network and streaming executives
always seem to have their axes at the
ready after all one of the key narrative
threads throughout the show's largely
remarkable 140 episode run was that time
is finite no matter how many time
shifting devices or bizarre scenarios
you encounter it's important to
appreciate what you have while you still
have it no it isn't shut your filthy
clam
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]